stream we're going south
the unselfbound
he literally rear-ended me while we're
doing 100.
yes correct yes
yes
I need to exit uh Calgary Trail
it is
this guy doing he literally just
re-readed us again
put your seatbelt on bro
Whoa man we're almost on 11th Street
we're almost on 11th Street yo yeah he's
holding him died he literally pulled out
a gun on us man
bro
it's behind us man
he is behind us
oh man
this guy's going crazy luckily I got
past some cars but
luckily I got past some cars he's behind
us today he's stuck in traffic behind us
now
but like Whoa man
where did this guy come from what
I don't nice no I don't see him he's
coming he's coming really yeah he's back
he's back yeah I don't know man I don't
see he's coming in hot he's right he's
dead behind us bro uh there's another
full of highway patrol officer there
uh
is this guy doing naeem Issa was driving
on the Hyundai on route to work with his
nephew Wednesday morning around six when
he says a red Dodge truck started
randomly chasing them he pulled up on my
passenger side and just pulled out a gun
and pointed a gun at us
and I was like what the heck that guy
just pointed a gun at us capturing the
terrifying ordeal on video Issa speeds
up to get away the truck still on their
tail he's right on me just smashing me
smashing me probably over 20 times he
hit me
I'm starting to speed up even more I'm
swerving through cars trying to get away
from him he pulls onto Calgary Trail
flying past a sheriff's vehicle on the
shoulder honking his horn the truck
catches up and hits him again so hard
Issa says his car went into emergency
mode and started shutting down
I slammed on my brakes he passed by me a
little bit and he slammed on his brakes
like he was going to jump out of his car
right at that moment the sheriff came
around the bend and pulled up like
almost behind us and he took off a red
truck is linked to a series of violent
carjackings the night before police say
just after 8 PM Tuesday a white Dodge
Ram truck was crashing into other
vehicles in the area of 117th Avenue and
102nd Street there was a confrontation
and an officer fired their gun the
suspect took off and was then involved
in another carjacking after that it was
definitely terrifying and having my
nephew with me I was just really
concerned about him and just getting out
of the situation safely then at about 7
A.M Wednesday morning the red Dodge ends
up plowing through a fence across from
Millwoods Town Center coming to a stop
on the grass right behind a town home
complex where police arrested the
suspect it was really crazy because kids
were about to go to school and
everything right so it happened just
before that it makes me happy that they
they were able to catch him and get him
off the streets
Stilger Global News